le travail ça va être de retrouver des
lignes en fait c'est une offre qui est
belle parce qu'elle tient en fait avait
avec très peu de lignes voilà on a on a
cette ligne-là on a cette ligne là on en
a eu ni si elles se rejoignent là et
voilà c'est simple et c'est en même
temps très très efficace et très beau
directeur d'une compagnie de théâtre
pendant dix ans jean guével a décidé de
changer de vie après un an de formation
quotidienne aux ateliers chemin de terre
de montreuil jean guével s'est installé
en résidence aux granges du domaine
national de port royal des champs
il est pratique la sculpture le modelage
et le tour une véritable passion pour la
terre c'est la matière c'est le travail
de la terre il ya vraiment des des
sensations fortes à la fois dans le tour
et dans le
dans le travail avec les mains en fait
je crois énormément aux gestes je trouve
ça enrichissant valorisant et puis si en
plus c'est le calme en fait il ya
vraiment un vrai une vraie adéquation
entre la nature et puisqu'on peut ce
qu'on peut proposer comme projet compte
jean guével fait découvrir sa passion en
animant des journées de tournage tous
les premiers dimanches du mois des
journées thématiques autour de la
fabrication des mots et dans gobe mais
son activité principale reste les
ateliers de modelage la plasticité de la
terre en fête une matière simple à
utiliser presque instinctive c'est du
modelage quand je parle des deux
sculptures c'est pas de la matière qu'on
enlève c'est de la matière qu'on va
ajouter donc on est dans quelque chose
qui est toujours en mouvement
sauf quand on a réussi à saisir la bonne
expression ou la bonne forme est là il
faut arrêter faut arriver à repérer ce
moment est arrêté à ce moment là parce
que ça tient vraiment à rien de un petit
peu plus de pattes un peu moins une
pression du doigt et on peut briser une
ligne l'activité est ouverte à tous
l'atelier met à disposition la terre
faïence ou gré le matériel et les émaux
ou engobes pour réaliser les projets
personnalisés
les pièces sont cuites sur place seule
exigence pour la pratique un peu de
patience et de concentration